[Music]
homie look what I become
all right so at the beginning of the
year December I call 2023 will be the
year of Investigations and it's proving
to be right left and right and by the
way it's not even over with this is just
the beginning today was a circus show
obviously with what they're trying to do
to the former president
uh some are saying well this is what he
did and we have to you know nobody's uh
above the lawn we got to get them and we
got to do this and we got to do that and
then some are saying this is the
weaponization of the justice system to
use to eliminate a potential candidate
but there's there's some people that are
saying wait a minute that's not really
what's going on did you see what
happened today with the 500 page Apple
uh research that came out against the
santis which Tom will comment on what do
you mean by that well they just released
it this afternoon I don't know if you
saw this or now we'll talk about that as
well dem's uh dump a 500 page of the
Santa's opposition research wait to see
what's on this website we'll go through
this together for you to see so there
some are saying well I think this is
happening because the real person and
they're going after is the Santas they
want Trump to win it so DeSantis cannot
you know go for the general because he
can beat him in general but he can't
beat Trump in the primary there's a lot
of different things that's going on
right now having said that having said
that this is a sad day to be honest with
you this is not a good thing that's
going on for the country it's just
because what this does is Revenge
politics continues but it's about to go
to whole different level don't forget
Trump's got how many kids he's got Evan
four kids he's got Eric he's got Junior
John he's got Tiffany and he's got Bill
Baron Fox yeah he's got five kids that
he's got all of them have the genetics
of this guy who's a fireball and the one
that may end up being the one that
causes the most Mayhem for these guys
the youngest one who's just 16 17 years
old because he's witnessing this the
most so you have to know that this kid
is living with this rage
so you're you're essentially creating
the second or the third another like a
Kennedy type of a legacy with five kids
that are gonna remember how you treated
their father uh in a situation like this
now uh Trump Tom if you can I got a
bunch of thoughts I want to get into it
if you don't mind just leading us with
the different you know uh 34 felonies
that they're talking about up to 136
years I believe it is if he does end up
if they end up getting them on all of
them the maximum sentence 136 years
obviously these are very nice fun tweets
to post for people who can't stand this
guy but we know how this thing works why
don't you take a minute and talk about
the 34 felonies well first of all we uh
took a look at the indictment doing the
same thing a lot of other media is doing
right now and we took a look at the
first four we went through them and what
he's done is they've done a thing called
parsing so let's take a look at it they
have you have one count of you know
filing a misleading business record and
that's related to that you wrote a check
then they're calling at one count of a
misleading business record because of
the invoice that Michael Cohen gave him
for that check and then they have one
count which is related to the voucher or
the entry into the accounting system so
there and then they have one more
regarding
um ordinal record keeping so what
they've done there they've turned it
into four violations on a single day on
what really is you got an invoice you
wrote a check you gave it to Michael
Cohen and you wrote it down the journal
that's really any sane person be one act
so it gets them to say 34 counts so that
I believe is a sensationalized headline
because normally what happens on these
is these things get combined later into
five or eight or whatever the counts
that they can they can hold water that's
the first element and to me it doesn't
matter what side of the aisle you're on
when you look at something like this
this is puffed up this is really puffed
up the second thing you look at is
they're calling it a Class E felony so
I'm like I'm turning off TV and I'm
going to New York State Bar Association
and the New York criminal defense
Association because I wanted to read
what is a Class E felony I don't want
Talking Heads or anybody spinning if you
know what I mean Pat so here's what we
found this is a classy felony a classy
felony
um there's a nickname for it bear Lee a
felony bear Lee Class E and it's so it's
barely a felony and most of the time
these things would be
um actually high level misdemeanors like
a solid misdemeanor this is the list of
classy felonies aggravated sexual abuse
in the fourth degree violent a criminal
mischief in third degree violent arson
in the fourth degree doesn't say violent
but arson's pretty damn violent computer
tampering in the third degree to defraud
multiple victims interesting so that
sounds like a Syndicate of uh you know
identity theft criminal possession of
stolen property in the fourth degree
acquired violently so in other words you
bunk somebody and stole a bunch of TVs
rape in the third degree now we're
talking rape and then what criminal sale
yeah that's a classy felony criminal
sale of cannabis in bulk in other words
distribution not just I had some grass
or maybe I had a bag of grass but
back when cannabis was illegal I guess
then criminal sexual act in the third
degree
now then if we get to welfare fraud in
the fourth degree that's a white-collar
crimes in other words maybe people that
passed away and you committed a bunch of
Welfare fraud and then falsifying
business records in the fourth degree
this D.A took this and pushed what is a
misdemeanor into the class E felony and
to make it stick Pat they have to prove
that the crime was a falsification
because it was tied to a second crime
and they're saying that second crime is
campaign Finance which
Hillary's campaign was fined for
campaign Finance violations a couple
years ago with no real headlines that is
what Bragg has done he has pushed these
into a category that includes arson
aggravated sexual abuse rape in the
third degree those are all Class E
felonies lowest level felonies in New
York state astonishing what Bragg is
pushing here this the same guy that uh
uh has got a 52 percent of downgrading
felonies to misdemeanors going the other
way yeah going the other way like I
committed rape and he brings me down to
aggravated that's right so here we're
going this first year back down greater
52 percent of felonies to misdemeanors
compared to 39 downgraded in 2019 and
had a this small 51 conviction rate for
the felonies he did charge so the
question then becomes when he gets up to
bad he only bats 500 which is terrible
if we want our prosecutors to be keeping
us safe but what what this really means
to the average person is he is soft on
crime okay so obviously this gets to
people to say Well they're using him to
weaponize the justice system to go and
eliminate a candidate that argument
keeps creating momentum uh with what
they're trying to do to Trump but here's
here's the other part
you know how many times like at one
point we were we were all thinking
Andrew Cuomo is going to be the
president one day Boom the left
immediately yeah they use them up when
they can boom get rid of them hey fauci
is the greatest thing since sliced bread
boom fauci is not being written
negatively about wait till his
investigation starts in the New York
Times and by the way his investigations
are gonna be very very ugly and we're
gonna see how many people turn against
them here's the other one that we forget
about Michael avenatti was supposed to
be a presidential candidate everybody
was talking about Michael avenatti my
god look how great he is look at this he
was the lawyer for Stormy Daniels oh
he's he's just dude did you see how he
handled himself did you see how he did
this guess who ended up soon Michael
avenatti his own client went up against
Michael avenatti I believe stormy ended
up suing Michael avenatti or he had to
collect she had to collect Something
avenatti Turned out just to be a
first-class scumbag he bought a Ferrari
with righteously acquired settlements
yeah that he he never he didn't just
take his third in escrow and then give
it to the victim he took all of it and
he bought for I think it was two
Ferraris there you go Michael laminari
is found guilty of stealing from Stormy
Daniels they were once United in effort
to topple Donald J Trump but even then a
jury found Mr of anati was stealing from
his famous client by the way do you
remember when avenatti tried to uh uh uh
scare a Nike and not happen to pay him
what is the amount he was 20 million
bucks no no it was it was it 20 million
it was a big number Michael avenatti
type in Michael the recorder avenatti
Nike uh uh uh where he asked for and
then Nike just reported it yeah it was a
big number he asked I'm going public and
your Stock's going down that's right
that's right and what was the number if
you remember was it a 25 million dollars
from Nike but I threatened the company
with bad publicity just a dirty guy
right so the next thing he becomes is is
it going to be Alvin Braggs now with
this is this the next useful idiot that
they're gonna use here's the part okay
that you got to give respect who is more
strategic the left or the right the left
who was more united left or the right I
would say the left is it fair to say
that the left right now is willing to do
whatever they can for what
whatever they can't for what 24. okay
but but but remember some people will
say something else
so I'll I'll open it up and we can have
this course on this is the left willing
to do whatever they can to
to win make sure no Republican wins in
2024 and they win or is the left United
to make sure Trump never gets a chance
to get into the White House
which of the two is more of a priority
to them I think Trump is I think
defeating neutralizing Trump in any way
they can is more of a priority because
he is a strong positive galvanizing
Force for the Middle America voters and
so many things are showing like in covid
to have been a fraud I think people are
waking up and I think they will do
anything to keep him out of the ring
that's not the guy they want in the ring
okay so then if you can go to the uh the
Apple uh of against the santis uh show
this the Apple research that came out
today against the santis uh matter of
fact just go to Google so everybody can
see when you type this so what comes up
just type in Google
uh uh DeSantis Apple research 500.
research 500 okay if you can click on
this
boom while all of this is going on
Washington Times Washington examiner
axios Dems dumped 500 pages of DeSantis
opposition research okay Bingo what's
this all about Tom you just shared this
with us a minute ago if you can click on
it to go to the site right there in the
middle American Bridge okay if you can
go there and zoom in zoom in
and Tom you were reading this a minute
ago go up a little bit if you can go
through some of the no I'm sorry go down
look at that one right there go ahead
Tom Ron DeSantis is a failed governor
and then they provide a bunch of links
to that this is standard opposition
research and it gives talking points to
any news media to use in St Louis
Missouri that doesn't have a research
Department
Security Medicare Ron DeSantis is a
bumbling corrupt and authoritarian
politician that's about covet that's
about Disney Ron DeSantis is an
extremist on the issues that's their
alleged don't say gay
keep going and then they've got
literally dozens of links some with
numbers in there none of this is a
picture of Ron DeSantis in college none
of this is Ron DeSantis got a drunk
driving conviction as Governor nothing
like that is in here this is all
opposition research neatly packaged so
that any journalist pundit Tweeter or
Newsroom in St Louis Missouri that
doesn't have a research budget can go
grab this and be ladies and gentlemen
this is what you see when you suddenly
see all the news media saying the same
thing at the same time they're putting
this opposition research out to take a
chunk out of DeSantis and he hasn't even
officially declared yes but but this
causes a different conversation though
Tom why launch it today
why release it today
do it today because everybody's going to
be talking about Trump and no nobody's
going to be talking about this is there
real fear knowing because when you look
at the data the data shows that DeSantis
beats Biden head-on but Trump loses to
Biden by two points but Trump beats
DeSantis in the primary so they want to
make sure that Trump beats so so then
the argument becomes both ways because
some people could say Well they're
really trying to you know make sure
Trump wins this whole thing by going
after them like this this is helping it
is the you're thinking there's that
Machiavellian where they're gonna be
able to do to give these eyeballs to
Trump for him to beat the scientists do
they really think Trump needs this to
beat the centers so with or without this
do you think Trump's going to beat the
scientists with or without this does
Trump beat the santis
in a Republican primary does Trump beat
the santis
we certainly the favorite however you
know it's a little too soon does this
help him or hurt him does this help does
this help him or hurt him does his help
or her Trump
I think Trump's going to use some of
this Oppo research himself onto Santa's
to be honest with you I think you know
if there's anybody that's been calling
out to Santos more than anybody it's
been Trump
help Trump
more to be the scientist or did he not
need this to beat the scientists
that's the real question I don't think I
don't think he needed this okay yeah I
don't know if you need it so then do you
think he needed it I don't think so so
if he didn't need this then that
Machiavellian thought pattern to think
that he they're trying to get him to get
more because in my opinion here's what
happens this is my opinion with this
whole case here winning the battle
winning the war I've lost many battles
many of them and they sucked and I would
watch my enemies to see what they're
trying to do to me I'm like okay that
hurt that was good good for you but then
I'm like but you're you just
strengthened me but what you just did
there was an event one time we're in Las
Vegas you remember the event we're
across the street and enemy of ours is
having a convention okay the entire
convention I'm getting text messages and
all these names that they're saying
about us okay we're at we're a smaller
company they're a bigger company but I
kept getting recordings being said they
just said this from stage about you this
person said this about you that person
said this about you and next thing you
know my Instagram blew up with people
saying hey man everybody's talking about
you guys what are you guys doing over
there for this many people to talk [__]
about you they must fear you right I saw
a the floodgates open of calls to me yep
they won the battle but then all of a
sudden we're getting the calls fast
forward seven years later of this event
this was six or seven years ago I don't
know the exact timeline but it was a
while back so here this is what they're
doing what was the mistake Democrats
made in 2015 and 2016. if you remember
what was the mistake the mistake was
they kept having Trump on 24 7. CNN
MSNBC
played over and over and over and over
and over again and then all of a sudden
one day they realized what was happening
they were helping them
yeah they're like wait a minute what are
we doing guys we're helping this guy
stop this is too much we can't do this
anymore and then it's too late he's a
president right tonight
this guy's gonna have an event tonight
okay and his event tonight
um uh his event tonight is he's gonna
come and give a message okay when he
flies back it's gonna be a fiery event
okay his base is flipped out right now
Furious whenever you do something like
this you best make sure you're right
because the track record Democrats have
of going against Trump they've been
wrong and they've lost nine out of 10
times
Russia this tax this that every now boom
boom fail fail fail fail fail all you're
doing right now is waking up to people
that we're never gonna vote for Trump on
this one they were ready to go to
DeSantis you just got some of those guys
to say what you know what I don't think
this is fair I'm going back to Trump I
don't think this helps them every
channel every publication every website
he just raised seven million dollars
since being indicted God knows what that
number is going to be by the end of
tonight that could hit a 20 30 million
dollar number all by doing this so Dems
may win the battle
but they may lose the war unlike covid I
think in covet what they did is in covid
Trump won the battle they won the war
you know what I'm saying because they
got them to get you know not get
realized correct until we look at the
finish line for covet is extending and
there's a second chapter that's here but
Trump's already well by the way it was
nerdy to say the least but you got to
give them credit to their strategy
you got to give them credit to their
strategy on what's happening there so uh
anyway so having said that Tom you said
something about Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton herself uh uh uh Clinton was
given 113 000 so when you go about
Clinton campaign class uh class these
expenses flashback to Hillary Clinton
quietly settled campaign Finance
violation last year and was never
arrested okay never in 2022 Hillary
Clinton was fined by the Federal
Election Commission after an
investigation showed that she and the
DNC misreported payments made to a law
firm during the 2016 campaign to obscure
the spending the AP reported last year
the firm was Perkins Cole which hired
research firm Fusion GPS which then
fabricated evidence compiled in the
steel dossier which was later used by
Congress to impeach Donald Trump the
Clinton campaign classed these expenses
paid to Perkins call for opposition
research as legal services and for the
misrepresentation Clinton was made to
pay a fine of 113 000 Trump is looking
at the possible quality of handcuffs
were the same charges
mischaracterization payments to lawyers
as legal fees when those lawyers were
passing on the money for another purpose
now wait a minute there's two things
here remember if you're listening that
money was in the Clinton campaign it was
in the campaign coffers of Perkins call
it was used for the Steele dossier it
was in the middle of it this money
was in the Trump Corporation to pay
Stormy Daniels this money never was in
the political campaign that's right do
you see the difference of course it says
Clinton and the DNC said the payments
were legal fees but settled for the
fines anyway Clinton paid a civil
penalty of eight thousand dollars while
the DNC paid the remaining 105. the DNC
the DNC correct so in other words it was
a campaign Finance violation period end
of sentence full stop whereas this is
the girl gets some money she's not
supposed to talk these are ndas these
are all over the place we've seen them
in other companies other places this was
not in the campaign and they're saying
oh but he was trying to mislead the
American people in the campaign listen
if he can't prove a second crime here
this is not a classy felony and it's not
34 counts and by the way to the news
media people that did the math did 34
counts times so many years to get 136
years you are such a fraud you know who
you are and if that writer is listening
you know you're a fraud that is that is
pathetic any person that was charged
with this the most you go to is double
okay well you would normally get four
years for that we'll make it eight
because you did so many of these they
knocked they they consolidate sentences
and do what's called concurrent
sentencing happens all the time happens
with killers serial killers this is this
so you read these headlines there is
such thirst in corners of the media are
you surprised though nobody is surprised
by the way Alvin Braggs just made some
comments if you want to play it Rob so
we can hear this
false statement
why did Donald Trump repeatedly make
these false statements
the evidence will show that he did so to
cover up crimes relating to the 2016
election
Donald Trump
Executives at the Publishing Company
American Media Incorporated
Mr Cohen and others agreed in 2015 to a
catch and kill scheme that is a scheme
to buy and suppress negative information
to help Mr Trump's chance of winning the
election
as part of this scheme Donald Trump and
others made three payments to people who
claim to have negative information about
Mr Trump
to make these payments they set up shell
companies
and they made yet false
hey look by the way you want to see what
Trump said about this here's what Trump
said about this table there there's this
legal team yeah I saw that Trump said
this about this he says wow district
attorney Bragg just literally leaked the
various points this is yesterday and
completed formation on the pathetic
indictment against me I know the
reporter and uh uh so unfortunately does
he this means that he must be
immediately indicted now if he wants to
really clean up his reputation he will
do honorable thing and as district
attorney indict himself he will go down
in judicial history and his trump-hating
wife will be I'm sure very proud of him
you got to realize you you listen say
what you want to say about this guy this
is Street Fighter baby this is a street
fight this guy's been trained for 50
years for this job he's been trained 50
years for this job okay question yes sir
and by the way if you want to just wrap
this up so while we're on this topic can
you show the hush money you found Rob
that the government has a fund called
the shush fund that we pay for folks you
and I pay for this Congress owes
taxpayers answers about his about his
harassment shush fund now what is this
some may say what do you mean by this
since when our members of Congress and
their staff accused of sexual harassment
allowed to hush up and pay off their
accuses from a secret shush fund full of
taxpayer dollars since 1995 it turns out
Congress we all know chooses to exempt
itself from many of the same laws
it voiced on the rest of us it's a
grievance I hear regularly during my
travels around the country as Grassroots
activists complain about the law or debt
regulation if only Congress had to live
under the same laws that we do that get
get it and they change it right if you
go below do you have the list of the
numbers uh Rob do you have that list
that you gave us to show exactly what's
an it's on um it's there you go if you
have to list on how much we've paid
every year of the 18.2 million it's on
page seven if you go on page seven and
pull it up so people can see this
uh is it on this page it's on the notes
that was sent to us I can take a picture
and send you the screenshot to show it
but this is what it looks like okay if
you don't have it yet and while we're
pulling that up there when you dive into
research on this there is bipartisan
intimidation so when a congressional Aid
or pages are called assistance and you
have promising uh college students from
all backgrounds get a chance go to
Washington work in a congressman or a
senator's office doing this and that and
then all of a sudden you're getting
invitations for stuff and then the
invitations get heavy and then all of a
sudden you're like you know stop
grabbing me and it's literally sexual
harassment well there's a whole system
on this and they on both sides of the
aisle Pat they try to suppress it and
disincentivize people from coming
forward because they don't want any
headlines in Congress and it happens on
both sides of the aisle rob you got that
picture let's take a look at this
so settlements every year since 1997
they came up with us in 95 the shush
fund if you can zoom in a little bit
more so they can see it 1997 it was six
cases settlements at 39 000 then we had
a big year of 16 103
000 you can see that in 2002 there was a
lot of mess going on there 3.974 million
on 10 of them then you go 2007 397 each
yeah I bet one of them was probably a
big one it could have been a bigger name
that we know about 25 at 4 million and
this goes on every year so now
this is a a convenient truth on how they
get to protect themselves but you're
eliminating a competitor a potential
opponent Tom right now
a couple names I'm going to give to you
and I want to see both of you guys how
you think they're processing this
obviously everything right now is purely
opinions and and and Rob if you can put
a poll down there and put a poll saying
does this help Trump or does this hurt
Trump let's see what the answer is going
to be on the poll Tom what is desantis's
Camp thinking about right now
what is Biden's Camp thinking about
right now what are Dems thinking about
right now what are Republicans thinking
about right now what I mean by
Republicans Tom I'm talking to Camp you
know McConnell
I'm talking about you know uh uh the the
folks that are not necessarily a trump
Republican the Rhinos right so DeSantis
okay Biden's camp
s Camp Republicans and Demps what are
they thinking I'll take a couple maybe
Adam will take a couple uh I'm gonna
take McConnell and I don't think
McConnell's happy McConnell is a good
legislator I think when he sees this
indictment any any lawyer or person
that's going to look at this and they're
going to think about the the Clinton
campaign finance and he's gonna be
sitting there thinking
man you know this is weak and they're
really getting this guy revved up so I
don't think McConnell is going to be
very enthusiastic about this at all uh
the core the RNC I don't think the RNC
is happy at all I think they've seen the
opposition research they see things come
out I think they're scrambling a little
bit I don't think they're happy
um I think that
I'll go to someone like Chuck Schumer I
think Chuck Schumer is going to put on a
brave face in public Pat but I think
behind closed doors Chuck Schumer is
Raising eyebrows and and and maybe he
looks a little bit like the emperor of
Japan I fear we have awakened a sleeping
giant because Schumer is smart and he's
known Trump for a long time and
Schumer's a street fighter and he knows
a street fighter when he sees him and I
believe that Chuck Schumer is sitting
there I fear we have awakened a sleeping
giant sauce
I'm just thinking if I'm the Biden Camp
I'm just reading the Art of War by Sun
Tzu and what's the famous quote when
your enemy is get out of this way just
get out of his way just don't even say
anything if you're Joe Biden right now
you just kind of let this circus play
out because this is a circus and you
know I I for me this is a very sad day
for America because I was generally
waiting until 2024 until the nonsense
a political season basically kicked off
but this is the kickoff of political
nonsense season so uh more than anybody
I'm sure there are a lot of people on
the left that are celebrating this I
watched even Colbert the other day and
you're talking about someone who used to
be when he was doing The Colbert Report
and Daily Show just such an awesome just
instinctual comedian at this point like
the you know to be a great comedian you
need to basically have the art of
surprise but there's no surprise at this
point he basically when they this was
what Friday the news came out that the
indictment was coming out you know he
says all right guys you know Trump got
indicted The Crowd Goes Wild
and for me that's a sad situation
because
more than anything I care about America
what do you think our enemies like our
actual enemies are doing right now when
China is looking at us right now when
Russia is looking at us right now when
Iran is looking at us now you're saying
this is what you stand for America this
nonsense right here and it's just
saddening to me because our enemies are
basically looking and being like this
[__] circus of a country is just
getting worse and worse and worse and
that's what they want and I do agree
that no one is above the law but I also
agree that nobody should be targeted by
the law right and I think that's what a
lot of people think is happening right
here
because this is about
hush money payment to a porn star okay
this there can be arguments made because
correct me if I'm wrong this isn't the
end of the Investigation season of trump
they're going to be investigating him
still for January 6th they're still
investing them for that phone call he
made to Georgia find me 10 000 votes
there's gonna be more to come and the
fact that this is where we're at in this
country is that the president has been
arrested and charged for hush money to a
porn star and they're using all sorts of
legalese and everyone's going to give
their million different opinions but at
the end of the day Donald Trump has been
arrested for his interactions with a
porn star you know you know it's wild
while all of this is going on we're
having a live podcast on Thursday with
Giuliani and Reuben yeah if there's
anybody qualified enough to talk about
what's going on with this for that
Thursday night podcast that was we're
having it's going to be uh Rudy because
he's gone through this mess so many
times the last 50 60 years but to me you
know while you see something like this
is is are Republicans sitting here
saying the following the Republican
voter the Republican voter saying man
shoot okay so let's just say we get
Trump
even if Trump gets only four years he's
not going to get eight years to create
momentum he's going to get four years
and after his four years would Trump be
willing to help the Santas get eight
years so for it to be 12 years because
the Santa is going to end up being a
president 70 80 Chance is going to be a
president so this time four years eight
years nobody knows but
is he willing to do that and if he does
are they going to let him do what he
needs to do in four years or is it going
to be like this every day every day
Trump tries to pass a bill a law
whatever whatever every day they're
gonna say do you know this came up you
know that came up and the Republican the
average Republican voter is saying dude
do I really want to mess with this for
another four years then the Maga voters
say no this is exactly the guy that's
going to get the job done who else do
you want to put in there okay the moment
they're done getting rid of him they're
going to Target the Santa's next so
whether you like it or not they're going
to Target anybody that's on the right
side this is the right guy to come and
get the job now for you as a voter how
do you process this as a voter you're a
guy that's a policy guy okay you're not
a guy that's like you're more about who
can get the policies done and get the
job done how does this get you to be
concerned about whether any of the
policies that need to be get done will
will he be able to do that in that
four-year period
well yes I'm a policy guy and
on one hand but over the last two weeks
as this has been slowly you know coming
to a boil and I've been you know I don't
just look at certain media and get
myself revved up because I'm only
looking at NBC and you know
you know 80 of that goes one way and it
frustrates me I'm looking at this now
saying you know what
this country needs to fight and we need
to fight back and against what we want
to slowly becoming this this standard
and you don't do that mildly you don't
do that with policies you you have to do
that very deliberately and very strongly
um and we saw it happen with the tea
party we saw it happen with um Reagan go
back and take a look at at this country
the Reagan Carter uh election didn't
have the internet didn't have all that
but there is a lot of tension there was
a lot of stuff going on and it took a
strong force to come back and drive it
and so yeah policy people may work in a
bipartisan way but Pat that's only when
Congress is functioning as a bipartisan
Cooperative Congress
if they're not then you need you need
the strength you need to draw the line
you need to hold the line and you know
it's the uh
it's it's a new world we live in and I
am a very
you know
pissed off voter right now is what I'm
saying I'm I'm angered to action not to
Revenge but I'm angered to action really
forcefully I'm not going to go lightly
with friends and family that I talk to
I'm going to be very logical as the I'm
going to be Tom but I'm going to be
pretty direct with them about what what
are you standing for this is not a man
be pamby
time this is you got to say this is your
country this is what you want you you
want to be like the Brits who have Prime
Ministers for 10 minutes we've seen that
three prime ministers in the last what
18 months and over what we didn't like
Breck said and Boris is a drunk okay
three two one enough votes out you want
that you want a revolving door or you
want to you want leadership and people
get [__] done excuse me
that's where I'm at right now
you know shit's real when Thomas cursing
yeah exactly I think you hit the nail on
the head is that like looking ahead you
know what do the next four years look
like with Trump and one can argue that
it's going to be even uglier on both
sides after all this plays out because
you know Trump's famous for saying you
know if you come at me I'm gonna come at
you a hundred times harder right so
let's say he's acquitted from this right
so let's go best case scenario for Trump
he's acquitted
do you know how vindictive and ugly he
could rightfully get you tried to do
Russia with me you tried to do Ukraine
you tried to do this you tried to do
that then you [__] tried to throw me
in jail do you know how ugly and
vindictive it can get and for the
country
you know and then the media is going to
come after him double down on everything
like I didn't think things could get
even uglier than they did in 2016 2018
and I feel like 2024 is basically like
yeah hold my beer buddy because we're
about to see how ugly things can get and
As Americans this is this is a sad day
because I think this is the the the
Tipping Point and the starting point for
when the ugliness round two round three
arguably is going to begin and and I
don't think anybody wants that um for
our country and the whole reason that
Joe Biden even got elected nobody was
out there rooting for Joe Biden it's
just they didn't want the Trump trained
circus that was continuing to basically
have a second term and Biden's proven to
be a Walking Corpse at this point you
know I think even dem's I think 60 of
Dems 55 of Dems don't want him to run
again whatever the number is today
um I don't know it's just that this is
not a good day for America if you hate
Donald Trump I get it I mean or if you
have trunk derangement syndrome I get it
but this is not a good look for the
country that you live in you know the
election we only know it eight to eleven
percent voted not Trump they didn't vote
for Biden they voted not Trump right and
it was the dissatisfied you know on a
scale of one to ten you're five to sixes
ten being liberal zero being
conservative the five to sixes on that
moderate middle eight to eleven percent
voted not Trump not for Biden and Pat
says this all the time there's 10 to 12
percent of the country that controls the
elect the country the swing States the
the Midwest the Rust Belt and there's
going to be polling like crazy in those
areas to see what they think about this
indictment and those are the people that
basically our country goes so we'll see
what they have to say about this matter
we all know that 40 something percent of
the country love Donald Trump and 40
something percent of the country hates
Donald Trump and that's not changing so
uh there's ten percent of the country
that is in it basically I dictate what I
have a God I have a thought on what's
going to happen but before I give you
that can you play the clip of him
walking into the court 25 second clip
can you just show this
just look at his mannerisms look at his
eyes
president Trump
will you come speak to US president
Trump
just play this clip on Loop on let me
just tell you
if he is sure there's our friend uh
Jason Miller over there get from uh
what's it get her what was it called
yeah get her if you
he's right there with Trump if you if
you think Miller about how he's wired if
you think about how he's wired okay
which is coming after you do you know
what this guy is thinking right now
think about what he's thinking right now
they publicly humility let me tell you
like for me okay let me tell you from me
you may beat this guy he's got five kids
he's got five kids he's got grandkids
this bloodline of trump is not going
away
they just effed up for 80 years is what
they just messed up with not 10 years
not 20 years 80 years
for 80 years you're going to have have
to hear this last name eight years and
there's only one strategy you can use to
prevent that name from coming up left
and right and you know what that
strategy is so I'm trying to do that
with Kennedy okay with that strategy but
this one's not going to go away for a
minute because Trump is more like Joseph
Kennedy than he's like John F Kennedy I
don't know if you know the difference
Tom you know obviously John Joseph
Kennedy was absolutely the guy that you
feared Vengeance I'm coming after you
I'm gonna come versus John F Kennedy was
a guy that never wanted to be a
president he was the younger brother
with the back problems and he had he had
health issues and his older brother who
was a pilot who was supposed to be the
one that was supposed to be the
president and he was the guy that the
day his older son died Joseph Kennedy
went into depression for a few years and
then all of a sudden the younger son is
like I'm on avenge I'm going to come
then boom John F Kennedy and then RFK
and boom the difference here is the
Father Joseph Kennedy equals Trump
exactly and Trump is the president to
show you how tough it was skip
everything you've heard about Kennedy
conspiracies there were statements that
were made by the mob that said I don't
know who did it I don't know how it got
pulled off talking about the Kennedy
assassination but I'll tell you I
understand it strategically because if
you had taken out because one of the one
of the benefits was that Bobby Kennedy
was no longer attorney general shortly
thereafter and Bobby Kennedy was
Prosecuting a ton of organized crime
remember that and the thinking was what
if if you were worried about Bobby
Kennedy and you're worried about how
Kennedy had basically was a mobster had
two sons in the White House Prosecuting
the rest of the mob
and if if you believe that
the thinking was why don't you take out
Bobby Kennedy and he said no no don't do
that
why because it still leaves Joe Kennedy
with his son as president and they would
have flipped this country upside down
and I believe that when I read that
assessment I think that's the right
assessment they made that if if Bobby
was really the target why don't you just
kill the Attorney General send a message
to family no no no don't do that don't
do that yeah well obviously we're
speculating we're just repeating history
guys we're not saying anything cure I
don't want anybody to jump to
conclusions what the mob said if that
was a strategy exactly that they
identified with that because they were
scared of Joe but but here's the thing
with this
you know I talked to a guy who just had
a conversation with Trump earlier today
okay one give the name he says we had a
call
and we we had to talk 14 different
issues together
and he's been a friend of his for
a long time and that's not Giuliani by
the way he's been a friend of us for a
long time and he said
it's wild how this guy at this age can
compartmentalize 14 different issues he
says in a 26-minute conversation we talk
about 14 different issues and it was
sharp on every single one of them while
he's dealing with this so what are we
going to do with are we going to do this
call this guy what are we going to do
he's like he is so flipping sharp
meaning
do you trying to tire this guy out he's
not there yet okay this is a guy that
may be living into his 90s okay the way
he is right perfect no problem but Tom
there is a different maybe maybe it's
different with the kid I woke up when
somebody called out my dad
I woke up when somebody called on my dad
I'm just a party guy you embarrassed my
dad game over for the rest of your life
you're gonna have to deal with me right
those five kids and the grandkids are
watching this saying you did that to my
papa you did that to my dad no problem
you're gonna have to deal with me for
decades so again
you won the battle
but this type of an event first time in
the history of America that you're doing
this you're humiliating the last name
you may have just woke up a giant and it
isn't who you think it is uh anyways
quick final thoughts before we wrap up
this is the second time this has
happened I don't know if you knew that
the first time not being ironic here
Ulysses S Grant was arrested and charged
for speeding with a horse and buggy in
the 1870s so there is some precedent
here but that's how ridiculous this is
It's been 150 years since something like
this has happened and it was a a Civil
War General ex-president president
president that was arrested speeding in
a horse and buggy history so ugly every
politician has a closet and it just so
happens that Joe Biden's is pretty big
and with Hunter and everything that's
there the tables turn on this and
there's different leadership you know
what it's just going to come right back
the other way and I don't wish that on
America that's more distraction for
America that's more laughing the China
and Iran and Russia just laugh at us but
you can see it coming you know what I
mean to us you can see it coming that's
that is a closet full of easy targets
and if it swings back the other way duck
yeah well look I mean we'll we'll stay
on top of this we got a story we got
another podcast that's coming up live uh
in two days in South uh Florida if you
are wanting to uh join us in this one uh
text the uh Word podcast to
310-340-1132 once again text award
podcast to get any of the updates on
what we're doing with our next live
podcast two three one zero three four
zero one one three two again text award
podcast to
310-340-1132 I have one prediction for
you Pat here we go Thursday night yeah
it's going to be on fire I think so on
the pbd live podcast I think
I think that's what's going to happen on
Thursday anyways take care everybody
we'll see you again uh we'll do this
again Thursday night 7 P.M bye-bye bye
bye